okay here we go twenty seconds until
kickoff of the war zone open I'm looking
for a top ten somehow this is a
two-minute warzone unrated currently 323
players average rating is 1786 time
handicapped time will be adjusted
according to player's rating 30 minutes
and here we go oh what's the scoop I'm
not I filled up with granola bars at all
so and let me make sure I get these
points doubled and let me make my move
first okay and we're gonna have the
Sicilian I can't try for crazy um let's
try the open Sicilian can't try for
crazy fishing pull tactics in this one I
should probably have a fob
well that's percent night away so I'll
gaining some space let me finish my
sentence there I can't go with the
fishing pole stuff I don't think because
of what because it's not a one minute
game but um this is a problem isn't it
light-square weaknesses the Queen's
ready to kill black right here on h5
takes takes Queen h5 chop here and we're
soon to be seeing some brutal stuff
happening in fact it's a matin - coming
up I bet you the bishop blocks its main
block with the bishop this is me back to
tournament - somebody already has three
okay so far so good
defender defender 89 who is a strong
player let's build a center build a
center build a center and close it up a
bit okay I'm a space advantage and I'm
gonna go with this I don't know if it's
right but I'm gonna try it let's break
this open give me the dark squares
please is this working
we're gonna see about that
can I take take take post a night here
and then maintain the night there I got
to come up with something quick and I'm
not coming up with something quick let
me do this first
hopefully it's working this might be
good let's see ah
unless that move is played ok let's back
up okay let's take with this guy my
bishop wants to play one day and let me
do this and I guess I might want to be
dealing with a knight right there oh
it's scary time or is it can I stay
coordinated it's a bit scary very very
scary right here but hopefully this is
working I want to queenside castle like
immediately and we're gonna have a bunch
of exchanges could be seeing that real
soon let me do this probably right and
and get trades back up there and Bishop
okay I could get to this square it's
juicy isn't it juicy square oh that's a
slick move or is it my bishops ready to
drop I can't take with my knight I get
mated okay let's trade trade trade trade
trade trade route to the seventh or not
let's play here what's that Knight gonna
do what's my time situation I have very
little time I spent too much time
get out of there Queen no that's a bad
idea
don't do it bad ideas can we trade a
little bit please just a little bit okay
wait this might be good Queen to d2 soon
Knights tricky Knights okay fortunately
their Knight can't go to any square
except that one which is good enough and
now I'm in trouble I couldn't do
anything about that anyhow that was bad
why did I allow this to happen
why am i allowing bad stuff to happen
I want to cry I want to cry I want to
cry I'm on the defense out of 20 seconds
this is not good this is bad news for me
isn't it oh I spent way too much time
way too much time there's a check-in now
I'm gonna fork or mi come over here I
spent way too much time didn't I
can I get this pond eleven seconds
there's no time I'm gonna offer a drop
they take a drop no I don't want to
design just ready to resign perpetual
what give me that check can I get this
Oh is there may coming up soon I was
gonna give a check at that night off any
time I don't have any time oh I'm a dead
man
I love a neat sir I wanna cry oh don't
watch that game again oh that was brutal
I had something at the end there too
okay you know what this means
ah it means I lost the game Oh
or am i hang on hey God move right here
can I get this back come on you can do
it you can do it don't you dare give up
check is this working it's not working
can I give a check here oh wait a second
how the Queens have to come off there
had to be something better there had to
be something better wow that was fun
while lasted wasn't it
yeah just going to checking spree and
then have all the fuel run out and then
you end up crashing that is a great
strategy right there yes do that a lot
you'll win a lot of games if you go that
strategy just check up around right
that was so beginner like I have oh you
have no idea
right those are new to chess go check
happy and that's exactly what I just did
oh let me give a check let me give
another check and another because
whenever you check it's got to be good
right come on get out there now I got a
win quick and I'm doing anything but
winning quick right now oh man what a
disaster
oh the defender killed me okay I'm not
giving up though don't you dare give up
my Knights look pretty don't they
let's see if I could put them to better
use than I did my queen Oh free pawn
take those free pawns chase away a
knight oh but wait a second pawn push
here okay wait you chop this guy and
then before this this pawn gets out of
hand let's chop him up okay I think I
have this one under control I think it's
not enough to be thinking though is it
Oh what am I talking about let's go b6
b6 and then what's this Knight doing
he's not having the best day
okay b6 let's go let's roll double up
actually I'm not in a position double up
just yet check and then play here it is
defended by my knight
Oh tricky stuff tricky stuff let's go
rook 4x I had a fork do the forks if
they're there there's a triple fork
everything's hit a lot of rooks are hit
right now both rooks
resigned time this is matin 1/2 just
take the pieces I've very little time
this is mate this is made this is my
packed event how are you supposed to get
somebody who has 29 when you only have 4
I have 4 I'm in 43rd another big dog
okay is this gonna work out okay we have
an exchange caro-kann can I win maybe
just playing solid I spent so much time
on that game that I lost that was so
stupid why did I spend so much time hi
this is a two-minute game
it's not an eternity let's get opposite
the king that's where it belongs
let's go take my night or not I'm gonna
try this even though it's weakening
that's a good move I think let me do
that I think it will really take and to
take that I'm gonna push my knight
around they're gonna push my knight
around
I can't Castle what am i doing oh boy
push here this is scary this is scary
but I'm gonna do it oh please just close
it up please I'll be so happy if you
close it up yes I'm happy what I've been
doing my knight now I probably want to
move faster right here nice and easy
hang on where do you want a castle do
you want to castle it all no you don't
right here is everything safe how much
time do I have
oh there goes a precious piece right
there I'm gonna give that pawn up
because I want to watch over this square
I have my queen covered can you take
that pond I want to take their Knight
no I don't oh man I'm losing again oh
this is bad
oh I got a defend I got a defend
please let this work somehow it's not
working my knight please defend please
do something good uh I'm gonna go for it
hopefully this works run pond do
something 46 seconds maybe that was a
bad decision do that over here I guess
this is bad news isn't it what's the
scoop here
I'll make sure this pond is dead and
then get my night back over here what's
the time time situation where is the
time here King up Oh those ponds are so
fast why are they so fast this rook
pushed my pond 28 seconds I don't have
any time where is it all going where's
my time these guys are brutal look at
these ponds oh that's a good move
can I get one of these guys I need to
get one of these ponds 22 seconds I
don't have any time no time to win oh no
time to win this one they have so much
time here I can't allow the Queen trade
don't let it clean
don't let the Queen's come off no I only
have 14 seconds please let this be a
draw best-case scenario please let it be
a draw please let it be a draw is it
gonna be a draw I don't have any time
though they're gonna check me like crazy
no they're not I got the Queen
oh hey God hang on they slipped up Oh
miraculous comeback another Houdini
surprisingly take it oh man I was
fearing the worst and the worst was the
last right there oh the lady comes out
never give up actually you should don't
take that advice you should give up if
you're down a lot of oh the lady is out
of right there she's gone and she left
she took off she's off to the airport I
keep from I keep thinking about the
happy gilmore lines okay let's stop a
pin okay Bishop to b3 I know they fish
up there okay Wow how do I win that one
I shouldn't have won that one
we struggled for a draw the draw is
best-case scenario oh man
okay let's regroup here can I somehow
get this beyond the bishop I'm gonna
take I want to keep my knight in the
center I want to get f4 and okay
actually let me take this because I'm
getting material what's the scoop I
might resign I'm in 30th place I'm
looking for just a top ten come on top
ten I couldn't grabbed upon as well okay
maybe I should just play more
aggressively if I'm gonna win the knight
has to move okay
or does it let's take here and then take
that pawn on c7 the Queen could give a
check though
that's alright maybe what is it I don't
know how the Queen give a check on c5 my
queen can maybe give checks on this
diagonal what's the time situation let's
come here I think or here one of the two
somewhere there's gonna be pawn takes
pawn I want to just trade Queens Queen
c3
maybe Queen c3 to anything I'm on the
rook no pawn takes I could take the rep
I almost missed that okay their time is
ticking and the first place guy has what
okay I got a I guess let's just trade
Queens I'm giving that up they have two
knights versus rook so this was not the
best thing to be doing I'm gonna land in
a fork I can feel it
those Knights are ready to kill me how
did it go from this position why did I
drop that night he was that was stupid
okay there's a pin here but hang on the
nights are getting tricky again those
tricky Knights the ready to land of four
can kill my rook it's coming here I
don't want that King to play here in the
center if I played here the King was
gonna play there let's do this I'm
dropping more material there goes upon
what's the time I'm struggling just to
win games here ah
look at what I just did to my rook don't
ever do this in your own games never
ever ever get in the position where you
have to do that to one of your pieces
they'll be very upset with you so get
this c-pawn going this is foolish
technique right here this is real bad
night right here is a good one more
pawns falling but fortunately they don't
have any time and if I have that on my
side maybe I could win games it's the
only thing I have on my side here
there's gonna be tricky Forks and stuff
there's gonna be rook over here check
check check no time though there goes
another pun down quick I just need the
bird time here okay
let's just do that I need to just
flounder about with my king I have
nothing else but the clock on my side
give a check come over here this is
fantastic technique let me tell you
fantastic technique being shown right
here
give checks checks let's not play here
let's come here I get out of a fork
check over here no checks here this is
bad
back to Turman 1858 is in first place
I've got place number 20 for 14 minutes
no quick wins in fact I think I was
losing in all games so far looking to
even be where I'm at and let's take here
and then grab this pawn because it's
free and then come back and hopefully
have something better to do in this
position is there gonna be a knight move
here looking for a fork and might happen
or not okay so now I have a beefy Center
and with this queen she needs to go
somewhere else cannot deal with that
Queen right here take with my king if
it's captured in an endgame this is a
this is good having these center pods
like this and the Queen that can move up
let's play here Castle and I'm gonna
play d5 even though I'm forfeiting that
c6 pawn the nice ready to come to one of
these this square maybe
not quiet let me do this no drop my
queen I should've done that first maybe
wow this is bad
okay Queen do something else I just
ready to drop my queen oh let's go hear
me maybe maybe Queen to b8 actually and
then play this role that would have been
better that would I would have screamed
right there if that happened if I drop
my queen like that after playing d5
come on b2 how is that defended okay let
me do this even though I can grab on b2
I don't want to do it just yet I want to
get more development in the King is
gonna run over here the rook will come
over here so I have this covered and am
i doing let's get this up here no oh and
I don't mean to do that huh
oh man mouse slips and stuff mouse slips
and bad technique is the the summary of
this tournament right here mouse slips
and bad technique pawn push I could take
this guy whenever I want
why am I not taking them I don't know
okay let's stop maybe push that
light-square bishop around a little bit
and maybe then the knight and then the
pond and then take the pot on B
what're what's what are they gonna do
let's do this and then and then do this
and now I'm ready to really do some
damage I think this is main - I know
it's not okay rook up and then over how
do I go over a cup and over right here
at this rook and then here where is the
main that's what I want to know less
than 30 for white and these are not
quick wins I'm only gonna get how many
more games and the Knight wants to play
here now the knight can't move otherwise
is b2 is main ah not good not good here
clock ticking there's less than 11
minutes I'm looking for that one crown I
just want a crown please give me one
crown top 10 is what I want no time
where are we at oh I'm in 20 seconds 72
they have nine games in double-oh-seven
here dragon double-oh-seven
maybe I should still be going with well
I don't know what I should be going with
okay I'm getting material on tonight is
the night gonna take there quick kill on
f7 no hang on your Bishop first Queen h5
let's see don't be silly
get developed Knights out Castle c3 d4
since I have a an extra pawn in the
center
d4 comes with great effect and this
Knight okay now I'm setting it up maybe
go on fishing soon maybe Bishop g4 is a
good move
get that night out of there and then
queen d3 may threat
it's gonna be seen gotta go for these
like silly little one movers go for the
silly one movers ah maybe this is what I
need to get back into
I'm in 4000 I'm in 13th can I just try a
silly chess somehow like just threaten
one moves one move mates and could that
actually be successful so far paid off
for a fairly quick win ah a quick
resigner hang on hang on can I actually
have possibilities of first place
I have fifty four those are two quick
wins
don't you dare count me out less than
nine minutes Oh guess who's fighting
back I might do better than just like a
top 10 might be top one or two can I get
the Queen maybe maybe take the pawn take
the pawn oh the Queen's dead it might be
a mate or it's a maid on the Queen I
mean resignation it might be a
resignation resign time come on this
could be a quick win hit the resign
button don't you dare let the clock tick
oh they're playing on come on don't play
on man oh they're just throwing that
this is the kitchen sink defense I'm
getting kitchen sink right here chop
blow up in the position here oh I am
getting kitchen sink right now kill the
rook kill the knight kill this guy kill
the knight next kill the night looking
for mates they're playing on why they're
playing on maton one two one the King
has run away don't run away this is me
to just move just move just move yes
okay back to German 7000 hang on hang on
a rough start but guess who's up there
in place number 270
oh there's seven minutes left that was
three pretty quick wins right there
one quick resigner time do you employ
the fishing pole fishing pole land or
not or maybe still hang on my queen is
gonna
oh hang on Castle you know you want to
castle castle
uh-oh it's happening close take the pun
take the bait take the worm okay I
insist
still take that night still take the
night he's free I promise take it with
the pond Oh Oh chucka ruski checker ooh
ski and I could get a fork maybe I
should just go for that they're gonna
resign just resign maybe will they
resign if I do that maybe cuz I'm not
material I'm gonna get my bishop here
soon before they get their Bishop there
oh I just my voice cracked right there
sorry about that one this is a problem
the H file G - there's some serious
issues right now big issues rook takes
pawn bishop takes here the queen is dead
dead queen coming up they have to take
like this is this time to resign they're
gonna resign they're down a queen now
this is actually the leading to mate if
the King goes there yes mate in what one
to one and then to just move just move
just move just move
don't let your clock tick don't you dare
okay good back to tournament what do we
got
88 somebody has 102 102 90885 minutes
and change wow I was not expecting this
to even be near the top Nonna fries
Nonna fries Oh No resign I'm gonna have
to resign resign er anon mover Oh Oh
what's going on here no a mover
this is a mover okay okay let's roll
with the H pun engaged engaged let's
close this up a bit
I guess the Knights gonna play there or
something let's give a check the King
has to run for the hills or the knight
has to run back okay oh this is bad pong
push okay
pieces are dying how dramatic okay i'm
killing the rook pieces are following
right here everywhere click resign or
not clock ticking it's a clock ticker oh
man I'm getting Noah fried right now bye
Nona fry what can you do what can you do
there's no the resign button doesn't
work for my opponent I don't think one
minute 23 seconds this is brutal there's
four minutes left there's maybe time for
just one more game I'm up a full Brooke
this guy's going down the flames right
here after the king moves are the night
rules the pond could drop this pond
could take h6 Bishop out queenside
castle a lot of good moves when you're
up material less than one minute where
are we at somebody has won 22 oh I'm not
even in the hundreds there's four people
in the hundreds a clock ticker I'm
getting clock ticked okay who are the
top dogs here this is the top dog come
on
white no excitement here it better be
that it is my opponents clock that is
ticking by the way it sometimes does
happen where there's maybe maybe that
isn't the case I've had that happen but
okay what's going on in this game
nothing in my game 20 seconds and okay
this rook is hanging take the rook Oh
black could have taken the rook it could
still take the rook and it's taken okay
gotta close out my game less than ten in
there's three minutes in five seconds so
I need to do some quick math here I have
to win in how many seconds okay back to
tournament 106 no no no no no no I don't
want to go to the leaderboard oh I don't
know where we're at in the standings I'm
in fifth I think I got 108 108 and I got
a win in 20 seconds I think
in order to be assured I could get this
game you can still do this can I still
get this in just castle please just
castle just castle it's good castling is
good right now
oh just castle ah they're not castling
okay I'm gonna go in this direction I'm
in a pen that's annoying but okay maybe
maybe Knight right here and g5 or
something okay I want to get to this
square how much time two minutes eight
seconds I don't have any time I should
take that pun come on what do we have
here I got this it's time I have ten
seconds to win that's me that's me
that's me that's me that's me doctor
tournament 128 leaders 142 can I get
another quick win they can always let
their clock tick but maybe if they are
not a clock tick or they will just
resign if they're beat come on can I
sneak another one in here that was me
come on f7 f7 going down the flames f7
going after it right now uh-oh and I
could defend uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh one
minute twenty kill the dark square
bishop and what next
I should get my pond going it's just
gonna lead to trades or is it I'm on the
Queen this is not great
okay gotta keep that clean away pond
push get out I'm on the Queen they're
not
this isn't gonna finish 58 seconds I'm
not even gonna win this one these pawns
are really far down and I got to keep it
closed I need a bunch of trades can they
make that happen let's try it a lot of
trades here come up coming up take take
take take take take take with my rook
scary there like this 35 seconds oh wait
wait wait
just move your king bag please oh no no
no she can I should just take in the
kwitny what am i doing I was on the
Queen I was on the Queen oh my just
taking the Queen are they doing this on
purpose cuz they're just they were just
gonna let their clock tick anyhow oh I
should've just taken the Queen why I do
that they're just letting the clock tick
anyhow oh it's complete right here it
says it they weren't going to move even
if I took their queen ah but I should
have done it anyhow that was missed uh
what did I get
well done I got a little pat on the back
well done champ they say but they didn't
give me any confetti because I didn't
get what top three but I got six crowns
oh man I got sixth place and I should
have gotten I should have been
I shouldn't have been seen up here
there's no way Wow let me close out of
that I'll take the six crowns I'll put
them towards the granola bars and by the
way granola bars are a food I get that
ass quite a bit like what do you mean by
granola bars or wind granola bars I'm
not people aren't familiar with what
they are are what I'm meaning by granola
bars
anyhow crowns are like quite valuable so
I just kind of treat them like they're
actual money